bonjour nicolas dupont aignan merci de
répondre à nos questions sur rt france
vous avez longtemps été le maire de
yerres dans l'essonne
qu'est ce que vous pensez de la décision
de nombreux élus locaux qui ont imposé
un couvre feu
mais c'est nécessaire quand c'est
nécessaire il faut le faire mais encore
une fois il faut appeler au civisme on
pourra pas mettre un policier derrière
chaque français donc il faut être
intransigeant à l'égard de ceux qui
abusent et il faut faire attention
comment dire de ne pas multiplier les
contrôles sur les gens qui sont
raisonnables c'est à dire qu'ils sont
sol qui vont acheter leur petite course
et de ne pas laisser des quartiers
entiers dans l'anarchie et moi ce que je
demande aux forces de l'ordre et s'est
donc concentré ce que je demande au
ministre de l'intérieur c'est de
concentrer ses efforts sur les zones
d'anarchie parce que on se rassure en
prenant parfois des mesures excessives
dans certains endroits et en fermant les
yeux sur ce qui se passe dans d'autres
quartiers
et ce qui est très dangereux
actuellement c'est que vous avez un
certain nombre des marchés d'un certain
nombre de quartiers où la police ne peut
pas accéder
parce que nos policiers n'ont pas de
masque voilà et c'est pourquoi je me
bats depuis des semaines et des jours
pour que les forces de police de
gendarmerie les pompiers et des masques
adapté ffp2 parce que vous avez certains
quartiers ou des jeunes
le cash et rassure les policiers pour
les faire reculer et vous avez des
scènes surréalistes
alors d'un côté on monte des images à la
télévision ou sur une plage déserte on
va les verbaliser à monsieur qui s'est
assis sur la plage je dis pas qu'il faut
le faire et il faut que les gens restent
chez eux mais je crois que l'important
aujourd'hui c'est de concentrer l'effort
de la police et de la gendarmerie en
leur donnant les moyens adaptés pour
faire cesser les autres de non droit
justement on sait qu'il ya des syndicats
de police qui ont
qui parle de peut-être d'un droit de
retrait parce qu'ils estiment qu'ils ne
sont pas suffisamment protégés a une
nouvelle fois la hiérarchie policière et
les autorités du ministère l'intérieur
ont été complètement inconsciente
il ya beaucoup de cas de kovy 19 dans la
police parce qu'on n'a pas protégé nos
policiers
ça fait des semaines que je le demande
un policier qui est en intervention
jeudi par les policiers dans les bureaux
je dis pas qu'il faut il faut bien sûr
delà de la halle un peu de bon sens mais
un policier en intervention doit
absolument avoir un masque ffp2 au moins
deux matches chirurgicaux l'un sur
l'autre
parce qu'on peut pas demander à nos
policiers de d'intervenir fort d'être
protégé et on a besoin des forces de
police et de sécurité et les mentaires
et j'écoute le monde moi au delà de la
sécurité nicolas dupont aignan qu'est ce
que vous attendez de la part du
gouvernement concernant par exemple les
mesures de confinement on sait que
demain il va y avoir le conseil
scientifique qui va donner ses
conclusions
vous savez en france en attendant a
multiplié les normes et à ne jamais les
appliquer moi je crois pas qu'il y ait
besoin de durcir le confinement
il ya besoin de l'appliquer partout
c'est tout et je pense que l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est pas de se rassurer en
disant on va durcir le confinement
on peut multiplier les gesticulations
réglementaire ce qui est important c'est
l'application du confinement avec bon
sens il faut faire de plongée ce
confinement selon vos wii il sera sans
doute prolonger on c'est évident mais
l'enjeu encore une fois fait un
confinement intelligent général pour
pâques et des zones où le virus puisse
prospérer
ça c'est fondamental et 2e points
inscrits au dessus c'est d'accompagner
le confinement le confinement fait pas
une solution miracle c'est de
l'accompagner par à la poype davantage
de tests notamment sur les personnes
contacts qui ne sont pas encore assez
testé en france est davantage de mac
pour qu'à terme tous les professions
exposées est un masque adapté et que
tous les français qui sortent puisse
mettre un mac pour éviter de contaminer
les autres
fate est l'objectif à long terme il ya
eu tellement de retard de prix que il
faut y aller progressivement 150
millions de masques qui sont commandés
qui devrait arriver ces prochains jours
selon les termes et leurs 2
d'olivier ferrand où ils vont pas
arriver dans les prochains jours
malheureusement d'après ce que j'entends
en tout cas il ya eu beaucoup de retard
à l'allumage il ya une prise de
conscience
il fallait la voir il ya deux mois
maintenant on va pas revenir sur le
passé
il faut bien que les masques j'ai
demandé au gouvernement précisément que
l'armée distribue les mac parce qu'il ya
eu tellement de retard dans la chaîne
logistique que nos médecins n'ont pas eu
les maths qu'en temps utile
donc maintenant il faut changer de
braquet vous savez on fait ce qu'il faut
faire
le problème c'est l'intendance
l'intendance n'a pas de suivi parce que
l'état a été désorganisée depuis de
nombreuses années ça fait des années
qu'on demande reconstruire l'état en
france
et on paye très cher cette
déconstruction de l'état au fil des
années la maintenance est un problème
d'intendance d'ordre de priorité de
clarté du discours
il ya des mesures à prendre la première
la plus importante encore que le
confinement
c'est de tester les personnes contacts
je prends un exemple vous avez une
personne âgée qui décèdent dans un ehpad
et il faut absolument tester tous les
pad tout le personnel pour isoler ceux
qui sont atteints et savoir qui n'est
pas atteint ça ce n'est pas fait encore
en france c'est impératif
c'est la condition pour que le
confinement est un impact après que si
vous confiné tout le monde et vous ne
faites pas les tests et bien la sortie
du confinement fera très difficile donc
il faut participer
merci nicolas dupont aignan d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes député de l'essonne et
président de debout la france